a secant line intersects the curve y is
equal to two x squared plus one at two
points with x coordinates four and four
plus h where H does not equal zero what
is the slope of the secant line in terms
of H your answer must be fully expanded
and simplified so we know the two points
that are on the secant line it might not
be obvious from how they wrote it but
let's make a little table here to make
that a little bit clearer so we have X
and then we have Y which is equal to two
x squared plus one and so we know that
when X is equal to four well what is y
going to be equal to well it's going to
be 2 times 4 squared plus one which is
the same thing as 2 times 16 plus one
which is the same thing as 32 plus one
so it is going to be 33 33 and what
about when X is equal to 4 plus h 4 plus
h well it's going to be 2 times 4 plus h
squared plus 1 well that's going to be 2
times let's see 4 plus h squared is
going to be 16 plus 2 times 4 H so it's
going to be 8 h plus h squared and then
we have our plus 1 still and if we
distribute the 2 that's going to get us
to 32 plus 16h plus 2 h squared plus 1
and then we add the 32 to the 1 and
actually I'm going to switch the order a
little bit so I have the highest degree
term first so it's going to be 2 H
squared plus 16
H and then plus 32 plus 1 is 33 and so
we have these two points we have one
point 4 comma 33 and we have the other
point 4 + H comma 2 H squared plus 16 h
plus 33 and we have to find the slope
between these two points we
the secant line contains both of these
points so how do we find the slope of a
line well we do a change in Y over
change in X so what's our change in Y
well if we view this as the end point
and this is the starting point our
change in Y is going to be this minus
that so it's going to be 2h squared plus
16h
plus 33 - 33 - 33 those two are going to
cancel each other out and then over
what's our change in X well if we ended
at 4 + H but that we started at 4 it's
going to be 4 + H - 4 4 + H minus 4
these two cancel with each other and we
are left with 2h squared plus 16h 16 H
over H over H well we can divide
everything in the numerator in the
denominator by H and what are we going
to get this is going to be 1 that's just
a 1 and so this is just an H so we have
2h plus 16 over 1 or just 2 h plus 2h
plus 16 and we're done this is the slope
of the secant line in terms of H and
once again we just have to think about
well the secant line contains the point
4 comma f of 4 or 2 times 4 squared plus
1 right over here and then 4 well I
didn't call this f of X but I think you
get the idea
and then when X is 4 + H well this is
going to be Y and we just found the
slope between these two points